all right tom is with us in Columbus
Ohio hey Tom how are you oh good Dave
how are you doing better than I deserve
what's up well I'm a new Dave Ramsey fan
and I just thought I'd run by my
financial scenario I mean to see if this
makes sense ultra just maybe a little
bit of a snapshot of our picture we um
we just recently adopt a cash load that
which is fairly expensive but we're
sitting with probably about 110,000
dollars left in cash and a while ago we
were convinced that the smart way to
finance our sons education is through a
whole life policy which I'm telling the
sign is not really the best way to do it
so what I was going to do we've got a
universal whole life that's got about
sixty four thousand dollars in the
surrender value which will put us at
about a break-even with what we put in
the first couple years or a loss but if
we move that over to a 529 and then
contribute about three thousand a year I
think that'll pretty much pay for public
college for our seven-year-old
but now in our newborn should we take
fifty or sixty thousand and just dump it
so it has 18 years to grow compound or
would we want to put that towards a
mortgage where where are these kids
going to school tom well I kind of was
trying to figure out what what college
is going to cost and you know anywhere
from eleven to eighteen years from now
and I'm showing public at about ninety
six and I've about 185 yeah so while we
upstairs yeah I mean why would sixty
thousand four I mean that that's a lot
for a seven-year-old to get to 90 well
that would put me at about a hundred
eighty five fouls all you're trying to
fund if he doesn't go to private that I
could carry it over for the little girl
right I could move that whatever is f
excess could be moved over to the
daughter right and then we could just
adjust at that point
well most 529s it depends on which one
you do is are limited to ten thousand a
year going in it's going to take you
really okay it's gonna take you a while
to move that into there you don't have
to roll it anyway because there's no
taxes on cashing out the whole life
because there's no gain right you've
lost money you didn't gain money and so
um based on the premiums you paid plus
what you put
initially so you know you don't have to
worry about that you can just begin to
move money that way but I would just I
would say okay here's our target and
we're going to set some money in cash
and systematically move it into the 529
for the seven-year-old same thing for
the for the newborn and you just come up
with your target it sounds like you've
been doing some work on it I'm fine
whatever whatever you want to do and
then once you've kind of got that set up
you can kind of check that box and then
any other cash that's left above that
you just start throwing it at the house
so that would be my next question so
four so we have a roughly at $300,000
house we have 200 we put a hundred down
on our way bought it a year ago it might
thought if I'm paying like four quarter
would we want to just advance pay that
rather than take the tax advantage of
the interest if we're going to be able
to earn six or seven percent on cash
well you're not taking into
consideration risk for one thing and the
other thing is this when you when you
pay 4% on $200,000 that's 8,000 bucks
okay and that's just using round numbers
right so for four and a half nine
thousand bucks okay so you're you're
sending the mortgage company nine
thousand dollars and your household
incomes what we're about 185 here forty
percent tax bracket and so it saves you
forty percent of nine thousand on there
so it saves you thirty six hundred bucks
in taxes okay
so you don't want to send the mortgage
company nine thousand to keep from
sending the government three thousand
six hundred yeah that's a bad trade
that's called a tax deduction if you
want to do that just to increase your
charitable giving it's the exact same
math you don't to be in debt for that
yeah so we don't stay in that for that
but of course you take the tax deduction
if you're itemizing and all you can
until you get the house paid off but I'm
going to go ahead and clear the house as
fast as I can and so you know if we set
aside
I don't know sixty or eighty thousand
bucks in your 529 plans for the two kids
to be moved there at whatever speed you
can do you know properly and you throw
the rest of it at the house you know
your back cut your house in half house
mortgage in half and then go ahead and
knock it out with your great income
you'll be dead for in a couple years
then you're sitting on a paid for house
education is taking care of retire
it's underway really and truly you are
at that point on baby step seven there's
nothing left to do but continue to build
huge piles of wealth and become
increasingly outrageously generous just
increase your generosity just factor
you'll have a blast with it it's the
most fun you'll have with money by the
way so good question man thank you for
joining us